president Trump authorized a new round
of potentially painful economic
sanctions against Turkey as a means of
urging in Kara to stop its offensive
against the us-backed Kurdish forces in
Syria but the Turkish president is
dismissing the mounting international
criticism of his operation saying Turkey
has no intention of stopping no matter
what anyone says observers say at least
30 civilians have been killed since the
offensive began Charlie d'Agata is in
Northeast Syria with the latest charlie
good morning well good morning in
addition to a Turkish military invasion
Kurdish forces here have the ISIS threat
to contend with now overnight here we
heard gun battles and a huge explosion
apparently a car bomb outside a nearby
Isis prison and that's not the only
place they're trying to break out a
Turkish shell slams into an Isis prison
compound
moments later Isis prisoners are seen
making a break for it
Kurdish forces already stretched too
thin warned us they'd struggle to
contain Isis detainees if Turkey attack
the militant group has already taken
advantage of the power vacuum detonating
a massive car bomb in the city of
Qamishli
where we'd been covering the aftermath
of a Turkish military attack that was
only a couple of blocks from where we
were we've pulled back from there but it
just gives you an idea that for
civilians you never know where the next
attack is gonna come from a random
Turkish mortar took the leg of
seven-year-old Sara and life of her 11
year old brother
she covered her ears not wanting to be
reminded of the horrors as her mother
told us what happened I understand there
was shelling in that neighborhood the
day before did you think about leaving
no no mother we were planning to leave
she said because everyone else had
already left you were five minutes late
we couldn't make it
has Sarah asked you why this has
happened even get this end yes she's
scared she says mom why this who's
attacking us and I say I don't know and
just pray to God to protect us now while
we were at that hospital somebody asked
me where I came from when I said America
that would normally elicit a warm
response but now many people blame
America for what's happening here they
say US military support was the only
thing stopping this Turkish onslaught
and now that's gone receive yes this
morning Saturday Charlie d'Agata in
Northeast Syria